to search pubmed for works by a specific
author enter the author's last name and
initials in the search box
use no punctuation
let's search for articles written by
fiona melanie wood a burn specialist and
inventor of spray-on skin
we've entered wood fm in the search box
click search
pubmen locates articles by authors with
the last name and initials used in the
search
if there are multiple authors with the
same last name and initials
find one article that you know is by the
author of interest
here i'm looking for articles by an l.a
baker who researches pancreatic cancer
the author we are searching for has
contributed to the article modeling
pancreatic cancer with organoids click
on that article
from the article abstract display click
on the author's name
clicking on an author's name in pubmed
runs a computed author algorithm using
co-authors institution names and subject
terms this algorithm finds other
articles that are likely by the same
author and moves them to the top of your
search results
another way to find articles by an
author is to use advanced search
in the search builder section
select author
enter several characters from the
author's last name then select the
author name from the autocomplete menu
enter
barrio d
and select barrio dj
some but not all pubmed records contain
the author's full name
for the most comprehensive results use
only the author's last name and initials
click add
then click search
to find all works in pubmed by this
author